a grand jury has indicted Marine veteran
Daniel Penny who put 30 year old Jordan
Neely in a Choco back in May this cell
phone video shows Marine veteran Daniel
Penny holding Jordan Neely in a
Chokehold prosecutors say that's what
killed him in a statement attorneys for
Neely's family called the indictment the
right result for the wrong Penny
committed these lawyers said their
client restrained Jordan Neely when
Neely was threatening to kill Subway
Riders the three main threats that he
repeated over and over was I'm gonna
kill you
I'm prepared to go to jail for life and
I'm willing to die earlier this week
Penny attempted to defend his actions in
a series of video statements and then
some people say that this was about race
which is absolutely ridiculous cell
phone video shows that penny
Penny had a choke hold for nearly three
minutes according to Neely's
attorneys
let go before Jordan died there is no
excuse for choking anyone for that long